this brand of mini pepperoni is made
entirely of pork it comes in a variety
of flavors each made with different
seasonings first they prepare the raw
meat they combine different cuts and
specific proportions to attain their
target meat to fat ratio the meat comes
from the pigs back shoulder and belly
the butcher loads the pork into an
automated grinder it grinds the pork
until it's the right texture for mini
pepperoni they load the ground pork into
a mixer and pour in some lactic acid
bacteria culture which will kick-start
fermentation later next they add the
seasoning mix and a pre-measured amount
of concentrated liquid paprika they
continue mixing for a couple of minutes
distributing the ingredients evenly
then they transfer the ground pork from
the mixer to a meat buggy they roll the
meat buggy over to the filling machine
and empty the contents a worker loads a
tube of sausage casing the filling
machine pumps out one point six ounces
of ground pork then twist the casing
between each one to form a link the
machine feeds 25 linked chains onto a
hanging line next they ferment smoke and
dry the meat workers hang three dozen 25
link chains on each smokehouse rack then
they roll the rack into the smokehouse
first they humidify and heat the links
to approximately 77 degrees triggering
fermentation the lactic acid bacterial
culture starts feeding on the dextrose
in the seasoning the process increases
the acidity in the meat preventing
harmful bacteria from growing it also
produces a fermented flavor after about
14 hours they lower the temperature and
humidity to halt fermentation next they
start up the smoke generator which
they've loaded with maple and beets wood
chips they run several smoking cycles
until the links change color and acquire
a slightly sweet and smoky taste then
they raise the heat again to cook the
meat thoroughly
finally they dry the links in a
temperature and humidity-controlled room
for a couple of days